hello and welcome to cydia playing the
jetty master exiled in Dagobah with the
Yoda picture okay play the red tea
gambit what are you doing with this
jetty Jedi write a return of the jedi
pronouncing this is always a little bit
tricky because we have a german way to
put also just less fancy it's just ye d
ye d master yeah so we have this line
here with e5 it's a decent setup for
black I like white you have to admit but
it's certainly a decent line one reason
why I like white is that the d4 square
is weak but it's not easily taken none
taken years off and white has ideas with
F form okay I'll push f for immediately
as a bit early maybe but okay so if i go
f5 porn porn storm style is that said
too much g45 actually this night has no
square so he has to watch out there a
little bit
hmm yeah understandable but ok this is
the idea each form then he drops back on
hmm each for night h7 probably
h 49 th 75 takes takes Knight takes what
is that some kind of direct idea like f
6 or something f6 pawn takes hmm I can
smash this right open but I don't know
if it really does much okay let's do it
okay that's very tough here for both
sides completely a very very sharp
position but I have g5 coming and it
looks dangerous really
yeah sometimes get this statement that
openings like the red tea they're just
totally boring I really don't see why in
many cases you get you get those those
kind of positions here where like
everything is it is very very
complicated and it's tough to figure out
with all the pieces on the board
think in many mmm openings that are
usually viewed as more exciting that's
actually you're not that much excitement
of you it's you think about the night or
for example you sometimes have lines
they're just theory for 25 moves and i
don't know i'm not sure what exciting
what's so exciting about just refusing
all that stuff what what's so exciting
about it t this is just interesting a
bit ok area opening has it's more
interesting and and less interesting
lines
John looks very tough to defend not
quite sure what exactly my attack is I
mean queen aged 5 and put it on the H
file i look at 3h three maybe just queen
age five and g6 the system may be most
straightforward way but we'll see okay
place g6 it changes some things of
course I can go yeah maybe just 24 I
don't know there are many probably many
good good lines yeah I was thinking if I
go like f6 here and Queen to h6 how does
it cover it maybe it's it slow but
might still be quite effective it may be
with a piece second g5 I just he just
arrives David ok I have ruge f3 age 39
hmm I'm not sure that I'm playing this
very precise length to be honest Queen a
one is also may be possible
hmm
and let's let's focus a little bit here
I definitely don't want to spoil this
game I would be very very embarrassing
so pushing pushing it back with this and
now I just need to get to the edge file
and your five even hangs
come on f3 now looks extremely silly
bird okay
time warning funny thing is I don't need
to check mate necessarily am I resign
yeah just completely just completely he
has no moves basically um yeah but but
still he also has nine seconds but I
tried this probably can meet him somehow
but I did it in such an incompetent way
that it didn't didn't work out yeah this
is probably not the best in the computer
just gives this this is stronger yeah
this is a bad idea just start with this
that also threatens right hands push up
to six it's much more harmonious and
then ruku f2h to it's much better but ok
this still wins because i have this the
Queen sacrifice him ok so that that
would be the way to finish it off I now
basically put all the pieces back but
it's just that his plate he plays with
two pieces down basically and this
should should be should be absolutely
decisive i can just played this in a
slow way and win like that yeah this
opening I think it's not easy for black
to handle I mean white has this plan
exactly the plan that I played and the
night over to c4 and then push on the
King side and this is some this is quite
sharp and not easy to play the way it
was played I think it turned out to be
pretty dangerous so
b5 yeah yeah the computer is already
giving white great advantage here you
know g5 and it's almost a wind according
to stop freshman yeah it is a dangerous
line he has to defend a bit a bit
differently i think maybe around
somewhere around here to be better
prepared for that that King side push ok
guys thanks for watching